Вони дивовижні…
Пухнасті…
І вони - у великій біді.
Всі ці комахи насправді бджоли, дикі бджоли.
І не виключено, що вони важливіші за медоносних бджіл.
Ми сприймаємо важке становище медоносних бджіл як належне на власний ризик.
Але чого більшість людей не знає:
кількість медоносних бджіл у світі збільшується.
І не лише це, а те, ЯК люди використовують медоносних бджіл, перетворює їх на проблему.
Поставити вулик на подвір’ї не допомагає.
Бо ми рятуємо не тих бджіл.
Тварини причетні до запилення 90% квіткових рослин у світі.
І коли йдеться про запилювачів, то першою вам, напевно, спадає на думку медоносна бджола.
Це тому, що медоносні бджоли та люди мають давні стосунки.
Бджільництву - тисячі років.
Існує багато доказів того, що вони відігравали важливу роль також у древніх культурах Єгипту та Греції.
Тому бджільництво завжди було дуже поширеним.
Аксель є головою Комітету з охорони безхребетних при Міжнародному союзі охорони природи.
Медоносні бджоли є вихідцями з Азії, Європи та Африки, але тепер вони є скрізь, крім Антарктиди.
Apis mellifera - найпоширеніший вид медоносних бджіл і найкраще вивчений, хоча відомо ще 10 видів.
Вони є так званими "головними запилювачами", адже запилюють більшість рослин.
І хоча медоносні бджоли страждають від шкідників та хвороб, кількість їхніх колоній у всьому світі насправді зростає.
За даними Продовольчої програми ООН, з 1961 року кількість вуликів у світі зросла на 82%.
Оскільки за ними наглядають бджолярі і вони також отримують ветеринарну допомогу тощо, то ризику, що вони вимруть, немає.
Але окрім медоносних є й інші бджоли.
Громадськість часто ототожнює бджіл з медоносними бджолами.
Ізабель - дослідниця екології запилення та урбаністка.
Це приблизно те саме, як коли, наприклад, ви кажете про птахів, а люди думають, що ви маєте на увазі курей.
Існує близько 20 000 різних видів диких бджіл, і вони є найважливішими дикими запилювачами.
Вони здебільшого одинаки, і, на відміну від медоносних бджіл, спеціалізуються
на певних рослинах, що робить їх набагато кращими для запилення.
Наприклад, на гектар яблунь для запилення потрібні десятки тисяч медоносних бджіл
або лише сотні цих диких бджіл -
бо Osmia Cornuta особливо добре справляється з запиленням яблунь.
Кожна квітуча рослина міцно пов'язана з певним запилювачем. За принципом замка і ключа.
Сабріна - керівниця проєктів у Науково-дослідному інституті органічного землеробства.
Це ідеальне поєднання між квіткою та конкретним запилювачем є результатом постійної коеволюції, яка триває століттями.
Як оці гарбузові бджоли у Центральній та Південній Америці.
Вони ідеально підходять для рослин родини гарбузових.
Вони рано встають , а квіти гарбузових відкриваються лише рано вранці, поки медоносні бджоли ще сплять.
Не любите гарбузи? А як щодо помідорів, картоплі чи баклажанів?
Цим культурам також потрібні дикі запилювачі. Такі гучні, як джмелі, якщо бути точними.
Їхні квіти вимагають вібруючого звуку, щоб звільнити пилок. І саме це чудово забезпечує джміль.
Медоносні бджоли не мають такої здібності.
Однак чисельність саме диких бджіл значно скорочується.
Це - загроза не лише для них та їхніх екосистем, але й для нашої продовольчої безпеки.
По всьому світу розмаїття диких бджіл щороку зменшується, починаючи з 1990-их років.
Головні причини - пестициди, інтенсивне сільське господарство та особливо втрата середовища проживання.
Нещодавнє дослідження показало, що ми, можливо, вже втратили чверть видів диких бджіл,
але зробити загальну оцінку важко через брак глобальних даних.
Під загрозою - понад 40% видів диких бджіл та метеликів.
Коли фермери раніше обходили поля, було повно запилювачів.
А у наш час це більше схоже на те, що все заспокоїлось, і ніхто не знає, де вони.
Ця втрата розмаїття може мати серйозні наслідки для цілих екосистем.
Менше різноманіття запилювачів означає меншу кількість дикорослих рослин.
Це шкодить тваринам, які використовують їх як їжу чи притулок.
І це також шкідливо для майбутнього нашої їжі.
Врожайність культурних рослин вища, коли їх запилюють різні запилювачі,
аніж коли це роблять лише медоносні бджоли.
Пам'ятаєте Osmia cornuta, фахівців з яблук?
Більшу частину запилення яблунь виконують кілька видів диких бджіл,
тому якщо до вас не прилетять ці дикі бджоли, ви отримаєте менший врожай яблук.
У США вже зменшилися врожаї зернових через зменшення популяцій диких запилювачів.
І загалом у світі ми садимо дедалі більше культур,
які потребують тваринного запилення - фруктів, овочів та
олійних культур.
Приріст медоносних бджіл за цим не встигає.
Це означає, що залежність від запилювачів зросла з 1961 року приблизно на 70%.
А у поєднанні зі зменшенням кількості диких запилювачів це означає надзвичайну ситуацію для глобальних поставок продовольства.
Особливо це стосується країн з великою кількістю монокультур.
Монокультури знищують місця проживання диких запилювачів, зокрема, у Китаї та США.
Але проблема не лише у цьому.
Те, в який спосіб ми використовуємо медоносних бджіл, робить їх частиною проблеми.
За даними Американської федерації бджільництва,
у США для запилення використовуються дві третини з майже трьох мільйонів колоній медоносних бджіл.
Більшість бджіл вирушає на мигдальні поля в Каліфорнії, звідки походить 80% мигдалю у світі.
Потім бджоли літають по решті країни, щоб запилити інші культури.
Більше ніде у світі не використовують медоносних бджіл для запилення так, як у США.
Але ця тенденція посилюється і в Європі, оскільки дикі запилювачі зникають.
У вулику медоносних бджіл у вас десятки тисяч особин, яким потрібно дуже багато їжі.
Вони з’їдять більшу частину квіткових ресурсів, не залишаючи достатньо іншим видам, що запилюють.
Якщо у вас багато-багато бджіл, то вони, напевно, переможуть ці місцеві види дуже, дуже швидко.
Медоносні бджоли також можуть передавати хвороби диким бджолам.
Заражена бджола може залишити на квітці якийсь вірус, і його підхоплює наступна дика бджола.
Медоносні бджоли не винні, але "рятувати бджіл" точно не означає додавати їх ще більше у довкілля.
Багато людей вважали, що можуть врятувати бджіл, завівши свій власний вулик на задньому дворі.
І це неправильний спосіб збереження запилювачів.
То який же шлях правильний?
Найбільшою загрозою для усіх бджіл є промислове сільське господарство.
Воно використовує шкідливі хімічні речовини  та базується на величезних полях з однією культурою.
В ідеалі ми мусимо змінити всю свою систему харчування.
Але на особистому рівні підтримка з боку дрібних фермерів також підтримує розмаїття середовищ існування диких бджіл.
Навіть більше можна зробити у власному дворі, наприклад, залишити вже наявні рослини у спокої або посадити нові.
Відкриті, залиті сонцем площі або, наприклад, старі колоди також створюють чудові місця для розмноження диких бджіл.
Але головне - їм потрібна увага!